I'm in Hull a small seaside town near
Boston in the Northeast United States
I grew up visiting the British
equivalent of towns like this I'm sure
it's the middle of winter it is so
bitterly cold here that the ocean foam
is frozen
there aren't any tourists nilly
everything's closed for the season but
this town still feels a little like home
to me there is one place on the seafront
here that's open specially today though
and it's the last play for cash
fascination parlor in the world a lot of
these did exist back in the day I'm not
exactly sure how many all I do know is
this is the longest-standing a hundred
years old
last year it was transported up here
sometime over the past century from
Coney Island and it now sits here on
Nantasket Beach there are 64 machines
here so on a busy night here we'll have
64 players the game begins with your
bill on the glass will range anywhere
from a quarter to a dollar and maybe two
dollars at a point in time we have the
entertainment and gaming license for
anyone to come in and play as long as
you're over 18 years old it is a game of
skill like everything in life there is
some luck that goes into it but
certainly there are some skilled players
that I witnessed over the past year so
here are the rules
roll the Bulls into the holes each time
you sink a ball the corresponding light
on the board switches off first to get a
line of five horizontal vertical or
diagonal winds or in some cases first to
light up the whole board and here you
win cash there are other fascination
powers but this is the only one or
you're not playing for tokens you can
redeem you're not playing against the
house you are playing against everyone
else and if you win you're taking their
money with the house taking a cut of
course but it is winter it's the
offseason there are no tourists so today
I'm just playing against Chazz the
governor do you have three balls that I
do I'm ready to go for yourself all
right so it's a dollar down the glass
we're gonna do it real I think I might
be able let me double check all right
bro don't go there all right all right
good luck all right three two one roll
them
[Music]
so if I'm to cover here playing to cover
okay it is winter right now so the plan
for the next few months is to
re-establish the arcade shake it up a
little bit in their meeting we're
looking to make it easy for everyone to
join understand the rules and get in
here and be a part of the fun Hey every
so often these games will peter out
because of their age and as a local
gentleman who comes in on a weekend
fixes them for us to get right back at
it the next week it is still running a
century old technology just a few
different components or changed in and
out of course they are all tied together
into one circuit and work amongst
themselves just oh yeah three or four
they're gonna catch up I think there's a
place for it to expand and grow and be
in a lot of different places throughout
the world but the reason it isn't
everywhere is I think we are a part of
the technological era and with different
ways that you can stay busy nowadays
cell phones and gaming consoles
televisions there are other things that
pull away from old-fashioned fun if you
will we're gonna continue to build off
of the history that fascination here on
FSK Beach has had for decades I've heard
numerous stories of the folks that used
to run this over the past two five or
six decades even more and I wish these
walls could talk because there would be
a lot to talk about
oh come on I've got one I've got one
what I love about this is that these are
century-old machines built with the same
relays that powered old telephone
exchanges and they're all interlocked
together in one really complicated
circuit no micro electronics no Wi-Fi
just a lot of things that go clunk and
buzz so on someone lights up the board
everyone on the sidewalk everybody in
here can hear it and they know about it
they're usually cheering all the lights
on the board go off and the gentlemen
calling the game or the woman calling
the game will make the announcement that
the winner is at for example table 13
the wall next the one I need winner
winner
ha ha good game sir okay gun and I'll
take that yeah now you can you any fun
that was isn't that the cool thing is is
you get these folks who have never
played before
yeah they sit down have just as much fun
as we just had and whether they played
it once or twice before next thing you
know they're here for three hours long
and as you can see it seems easier than
it actually is all like and everything
undead yeah you cannot I mean look at
you trying probably twelve times yeah
thank you yes sir thank you town
thank you chance an old team here at the
Paragon boardwalk you can pull down the
description for more about them and
about the fascination power
you